covered 19 and there is good news and
bad news
i'll start with bad news first but don't
worry the good news is is really quite
good
uh the bad news is though cases are
rising this line just shows you
uh cases daily cases across the uk
obviously you can see that spike that we
had in the winter almost
like two waves uh there and that's the
kent variant in particular the one
that's
kicking in in december and january but
what you can probably just about make
out is on the far right hand side that's
where we are right now so growth
rate doesn't look like much does it but
the key thing here and
you'll remember this is we need to look
at this with a logarithmic axis
which kind of displays the same data but
just gives you a sense of the growth
rate and here
same data exactly the same data but it's
logarithmic scale which basically shows
you the steeper those lines are
the faster they're growing and cases are
going up not quite as steep as they were
a couple of weeks ago but nonetheless
going up pretty sharply
and the big question is whether that
turns into more hospitalizations
uh and more depth now that's not the
only thing obviously
that could go wrong with catching covert
there are lots of cases of long covered
as well but for most of this pandemic
we've been really worried about that
turning into
levels of death further down the line
but here's the thing
this might well prove to be the most
consequential chart of all
all these bars are showing you is case
fatality rates it's the percentage of
people who get
the disease who go on sadly to die later
and we've got different variants here so
you've got the kent variant on the left
that's the alpha kent we could now call
it alpha but it used to be called kent
uh then you've got the beta in the
middle that's the south african variant
and look at them both of them so two
percent for kent so that's two percent
percent of people who get the camp
variant eventually go on
uh to die then with beta 1.5 percent uh
but have a look at delta this is the
indian variant and see where that comes
in in comparison
just look how low it is 0.3 percent of
those who get delta are going on to die
at the moment now
it's early days okay we've only got a
few numbers uh
for this like a few weeks worth of you
months worth to look at but so far that
is really encouraging
and it's not because the disease has got
less virulent you know all of the
other evidence suggests that it's pretty
much as virulent that it's uh
potentially as lethal
but it's obviously vaccinations more
people being vaccinated at that point
means that fewer people
are dying as a result of that and that
extrapolates into
this chart i was showing you this a
second ago cases let's put deaths up
against it
and see if you can notice a pattern so
you can see for most of this pandemic
those two lines have been really
correlated
uh with each other you can see the
winter wave and there are deaths and
obviously they have them kind of you
know later than cases so i'll move that
death line slightly
uh back a bit it's 14 days back so you
can just see
and what you can perhaps just make out
on the right hand side is look there is
a
gap opening up between cases and deaths
this is the good news story
it doesn't look like cases are turning
into deaths in anything like the way
that they were
previously but of course deaths happened
some way down the line if they do indeed
with covid
what we need to look at as well as that
is hospitalizations to get potentially
an
early sense of where we may be heading
so same chart again
and what i'm going to do is just put
hospitalizations uh on it
right now by the way cases up to about
12 300 hospitalizations where are they
well emissions about 222. and again
the lines are similarly correlated
aren't they throughout most of that
winter peak
but just look at where we are now it
does seem to be a bit of a divergence
and the question is what happens next
and i should say you know both of those
lines are growing so you've got growth
of about 4.7 when it comes to uh cases
uh 3.4
when it comes to hospitalizations
doesn't sound like much difference but
when i just extrapolate
those growth rates on the next few weeks
here's what happens cases
get up to about 40 000 by july the 19th
that's about two-thirds of where they
were in the winter peak you see that
line's very high isn't
it but if you do the same thing just
extrapolating recent growth rates
on hospitalizations you're up to about
560
uh by july the 19th now that's about one
in ten about kind of a tenth just over a
tenth of where we were
uh in the peak and communicating that's
going to be really difficult isn't it
because
what's july the 19th that's freedom day
and on freedom day we could have
two-thirds of the level of cases that we
had at the peak in winter that's going
to make everyone very nervous indeed
so the question is whether those two
lines you know whether that link has
been broken and whether those trends
continue but right now the trends are
suggesting
quite a big divergence and that's
encouraging because you'll probably
remember charts like this that we saw
around the time of the prime minister
announcing those dates well data not
dates he said
uh for reopening this was potential
scenarios from imperial when it came to
the next few months this is
hospitalizations and you can see those
those lines and those banded areas
they're just kind of confidence areas
you can see that's where they thought we
might head with hospitalizations
what has happened in the actual kind of
eventuality we'll have a look at those
dots on the far left hand side and i'm
going to show you what actually happened
in the following months
just look at those those dots so we are
really low
in comparison with a lot of those
scenarios and bear in mind none of those
scenarios expected there was going to be
a delta variant which is more
transmissible
but of course they didn't expect the
lockdown was going to be extended a
little bit
but even so we are about in line with if
not
totally slightly below that best case
scenario so that's really encouraging it
goes back to that last chart i showed
you a moment ago
it's not just cases we need to look at
hospitalizations uh because that's
really important when it comes
to actual outcomes uh for people i
should say you know
uh there's been various daily pieces of
data out recently some people have been
asking whether
the latest case data correlates well
with what we're getting from other
sources well
uh it pretty much does at the moment so
black line again we've seen that since
the start that's case data
uh you can see it's starting to go up a
bit that slightly bluer line the lighter
blue line
that's the latest ons survey data so a
better measure of what's going on with
infections across the uk again i've just
put them on different axes so you can
see the correlation
and they're still pretty well correlated
ons actually
it suggests it's rising at the moment
but not quite as fast
as the data we're getting on dashboard
each day but nonetheless it is starting
to pick up
according to the ons the interesting
thing actually and this was in the ons
data
but also in this chart i'm going to show
you now is just how much different parts
of the uk
uh differ so that's just this actually
is england
but if we look across the uk at
different growth rates we'll have a look
at this
this is just showing you covered case
rates and just look scotland
is seeing case rates rising far faster
than many parts
uh other parts of the uk england uh in
second place as it were
uh and then it's not a race you want to
win obviously and then northern ireland
and then wales
uh at uh the bottom there but you can
see all parts
rising at the moment but as i say cases
aren't everything
we really need to focus on other things
and actually you know you can go
down wormholes on this and it's you've
got to be a bit careful when you look at
these numbers because for instance okay
there was a chart recently doing the
rounds about how it looked terrifying
for the uk because our cases are going
up so fast and everyone else
in europe is going down this this is
more or less what the chart was showing
you so that red line is the uk let me
highlight it the red line
uh is the uk and those other lines are
uh germany and france
uh italy and the us as well and you can
see indeed they are going down the uk is
going up but
bear in mind we are testing a lot more
than most other countries uh around the
world
and that means that broadly speaking any
increase in growth is going to look
pretty sharp uh when it comes to the uk
so compare other charts i'm going to
bring a different chart on compare
something like hospital emissions
and while the uk certainly is rising it
doesn't look like we're kind of going
out up into the stratosphere like we
might have like it might have looked in
the other chart in fact we're
going up but relatively gently at the
moment you saw that previous chart i
showed you this is just comparing it
with countries around the eu same thing
with death in fact with deaths we're
well below
most other countries that are kind of
focused on here
it's worth bearing all of this in mind
because the hope is that we have
potentially broken
that chain and what's really happening
right now
uh is this thing this is just showing
you how much of the delta variant that
indian variant there is
in various countries around the eu and
what you can see from this
is that the uk had that increase about a
month or so
before everyone else but now you're
starting to see other countries starting
to get more
of the delta variants sweden spain
germany and the rest are starting to
pick up
so it's more the case that the uk is
just slightly earlier
along this curve than many other
countries uh in the eu and elsewhere are
there are of course big questions about
how it was that the uk
allowed uh delta to get into our system
before other people you'll probably
remember we've talked about that
quite a lot in the past about whether
india should have been put on the red
list
earlier but nonetheless this is where we
are and like i say although there is
something worrying and seeing cases
going up and although
for many people you know they could
still lead to other consequences for
instance long covered
nonetheless the good news is that link
between cases
and hospitalizations and deaths does
seem
to be weakening we'll keep you up to
date on how that evolves
in the next few weeks